Germany says President Trump and German
leader Angela Merkel spoke by phone
about Russia's claim to have a new
generation of nuclear weapons Russian
President Vladimir Putin announced the
new weapons in a sabre-rattling speech
yesterday it's raising concerns about a
cold war style arms race Elizabeth
Palmer is in London
Elizabeth good morning good morning yes
president Putin's threats came in the
annual State of the Nation Address and
in both language and in tone recalled
the very chilliest days of the Cold War
speaking to lawmakers President Putin
warned that Russia had developed an
array of powerful new weapons with
nuclear capability the showpiece a new
missile that was nuclear-powered he
claimed and had unlimited range so
missile defense systems would be useless
against it in an interview with NBC the
Russian president was asked to confirm
the new missile was actually operational
how do you have a workable ICBM that's
powered by nukes that you've tested
successfully all of those tests were
successful it's just each of these
weapon systems is at a different stage
of readiness not a straight answer and
Western analysts doubt there's anything
revolutionary in the Russian arsenal
anyway Western intelligence agencies
keep a close eye on Russia's weapons
development Pentagon spokeswoman Dana
White we're not surprised by the
statements and the American people
should rest assured that we are fully
prepared
Russia has long had a fearsome arsenal
but it's old and needs updating the
innovations Putin mentioned in his
speech like the unmanned submarine that
could eventually fire a nuclear warhead
are part of a modernization program but
not the start of a dangerous new arms
race it's natural to be worried about
that I don't see it as us on the sort of
edge of our seats in terms of a
potential nuclear conflict in any way
shape or form but we do need to be
vigilant about this one other thing to
keep in mind mr. Putin is facing a
presidential election in less than three
weeks
we all know that looking and talking
Duff goes down very well with Russian
voters Gail yes we do Elizabeth Palmer
thank you for pointing out mr. Putin's
not a straight answer duly noted got it
and Thank You Liz